[Singing]
Skrattar du!
Förlorar du, mannen!
Welcome everyone to skrattar du förlorar du. (This man needs help)
YouTube's favorite show. t-series is losing so hard. I bet I bet t-series is thinking: Oh we beat him. Yeah
We're gonna laugh at some clips here today, but will you accept this challenge please it will be my last request from t-series
PLEASE!
Smash like smash like
Smash like on the video
Smash like got damn it
Jesus Christ
Hurry up hurry up. Come on
Come on
Laughing Boi heheheheheheehehheheehh
more laughing
I Feel like this is exactly how I would react if someone this this to me sometimes when people just wake me up at night
I just start screaming because I don't know what's happening. It's my body adjusting to the concept of consciousness
It just doesn't want to deal with it
He just wanted to die. Oh, yeah, you know if somebody in the house
Oh, yeah, I reckon I want kids just to troll them like this. That's that's just beautiful
I feel like that's the only good thing about kids is they control the living hell out of them. Look at my bar
Look at that bar. It is full it got recharged from that shit dawg. How about your life? How's your life to going?
No one cares literally no one cares Vader is waiting around anywhere to scare me cuz all freaked out
Was that it actually in an anime? Oh
This is a person yeah, it's a persona you'll never see him tell
Perfect dance let's show it synchronize. Oh god, what's happening? See? All right
What is he doing
they stole Pikachu do something do something
hehehe
When t-series beats PewDiePie, they're never saving
god dam it t-series ah
What's happening - Pikachu looks like it's trying to eat himself, that Pikachu on a bad thing. We'll get those. It's alright
heha
Your mom took my corporal cat looks like corporal cat is  lagging
You ragequit it ran away oh
My god what oh
God yeah, it's pretty sexy. What can I say?
Why am I watching this I have a lot of questions right now
There's dolphins get the N word pass because that's not okay for dolphins to do that. They're not black all your fish
Like I don't get it guys that's what they're trading it's a hamster again
Everyone has to do something for the hundredth time. Oh
Why is no one made a pewdiepie version of this meme it's so beautiful, please. Have you smashed like yet?
Someone actually
Spent time printing out and cutting out. This is what I'm saying for
So long memes were created just to halt the progression of mankind
There's no way anyone would spend time doing this back in the day no one thought to themselves
Hey, you know, what would be funny if I print out a bunch of faces or Michael Jackson and put them on stickman figures
No one thought about that in the medieval ages. No one thought about that when we were during a toga new game around
Alright a booga dooga doing you see what I'm saying here. You see what I'm saying?
Humanity has reached its peak
Saltador hey. Oh, yeah
Cool, no particular car years and you cannot do in its cosmetic could no car
scuzz konoka
terminal machinery, is that the actual I
Haven't even watched Jojo and I got the reference why have I not watched Jojo is clearly everything I ever won from an anime
Worse meme obscene Jesus Christ, not even trying I did laughs
I didn't laugh if I laugh then the health bar would still be intact.
So point proven liberals
Really good. Oh my god, it's me
Jesus Christ see this is the kind of enthusiasm
I expect when I asked for a freakin bro fish not today
You have not deserved that then
You know very well what you did wrong if you think I'm angry now just wait until I'm angry when T-series passes me
Well, you know that I'm swaggin you should go berd Osama bin Laden
I was his heartfelt. I felt thank god. Damn. I felt they
Hey, bring, you know that I'm swaggin. You should go with beer Osama bin
Let's move on before it gets to mother tanks
She got waves
Beldo fing got waves, but it's not even weighs it weights out of him now dammit. This meme has always been this bad
Why is no one given me waves? That's why I'm angry right now. What all this is trauma. I will call my mama
That's a beautiful man. Hi mama. Oh
Hang up on my mama. Hang up on my mom. I've been sad mama. I appreciate you
Christ you should go to therapy man. I don't really know the details but every single day she
Dog like a month. I don't understand. That was a great Clayton much tank. Well done. Good thing
I have a little zip, but don't eat it out of the dark
Bitch only I can do it because I have this monster jet. All right, which is really questionable at this point
That was legit, I like that good aesthetic
Sometimes I just forget I'm recording a video and there's a certain level of professionalism that needs to be involved. I am sorry
Alright enough playing around. I see my health bar and I realize it's time for me to yeah
No more laughing. Let's freakin do this
Whoo that was hard that was hard
God dammit
Just doing of some review for my test. Just remember one way to read faster is
Is to read faster damn
That's some thousand IQ shit
[You ain't gettin' no translation here!]
No, one translate if you're Swedish do not translate like do not do it. It's not worth it
It's gonna be bathe major chaos you to shut down stock. Go to zero next clip everyone. I
Want every gun we have to fire on that man, that's CGI Oh
That's pretty good
Wolford will know blades. Oh, he got a blade. He's got it
What for nothing, it's just wrong. He's gone into stage two
The Lord behind why he has that blade it's red (Yee)
Why do you never do epic stuff like that, huh? All you do is freaking sleep
What are you gonna do jump off a bridge like sleeping? And what are you gonna do?
Let's watch the last clip together like a real family. I
Locked it down
God damn it
Okay, everyone that was another episode of
What am I recording your life you lose? That's right, everyone
Smash like very silently on the video cuz you sleeping. See you guys next week. Okay, you want to say anything?
Well, that's racist. You can't say that you want pyramids. We got him. Oh, you're into castles, huh?
We got you covered baby. You want some bets easy?
We got it all
This game is still relevant. God damn it